okay so continuing our discussion on
spider-man Clone Saga again spider-man
Clone Saga is 95 percent just bluff and
like five percent important things
things that actually matter which is
kind of an interesting scenario but in
this one we focus on Kaine now here's a
funny thing about this remember came was
just this enigmatic cloak-and-dagger guy
we didn't really know anything about him
until the story the truth is out there
which is part of the trial of Peter
Parker which will actually be the next
video that we do up until this point
King was just this guy that just how did
the footsteps have been Reilly kind of
the footsteps of Peter Parker and we
didn't really know anything which is
kind of cool it was it was kind of
interesting to see him become such an
enigma but what this story does is it
actually picks up prior to the events of
a battle between Peter Parker and
vulture and so on which actually led to
Peter Parker being poisoned now the
funny thing about this is that this
involves a character of course you know
Doctor Octopus but also involves a
character named Stunner
now Stunner I feel like we've talked
about her and I want to say it was in
one of the superior spider-man stories
but it may be that it was one of the
aftermath stories the I guess the return
of Peter Parker I don't remember off the
top of my head I want to say that it was
though but on the off-chance we didn't
talk about her stutter as we see her
here is not actually what she looks like
stunner is a chick who is kind of
overweight to be honest and this is
actually a technological body that
allows her to walk around and look at
tractus so it was actually kind of a
weird scenario but her and Doctor
Octopus have formed at least as close to
a relationship as you can have and
Stunner was genuinely in love with him
and he was genuinely in love with her
the funny thing about this though was
that it allowed the character to
basically kind of you know live out
alongside dr. octopus which meant that
she was basically his you know cohort
partner in crime sort of speaking and
the two of them one engages a pretty
nefarious activities in terms of
committing crimes and so on and so forth
now the reason why this matters is
because of the fact that Dr Octopus is
love for Stunner well actually be is
downfall but the crazy thing about this
is that following Peter Parker's
exposure to this sort of you know
chemical poison at the hands of the
vulture if Doctor Octopus is actually
the one that's trying to work on and
trying to resurrect amalgam this entire
time Aunt May is extremely sick and
virtually on the on the verge of her
deathbed the funding enough she'll
actually recover but again this all
really deals with the idea of Peter
Parker on the verge of essentially dying
so what ends up happening here is Peter
Parker of course you know recovers
temporarily there's
Dr Octopus basically says look you know
here's a serum that will temporarily
cure him and then were just going to gut
muffled a rooftop so he'll never know it
was me to take care of him which is kind
of funny because in the Peter Parker
just kind of wakes up and is like yeah
you know I beat this virus and that's
really about it now of course again came
constantly in the background constantly
watching things unfold looking at Mary
Jane Watson looking at Stunner these
different characters and just sort of
watching these events progress so what
ends up happening here as in this this
really interesting moment Doctor Octopus
sort of leaves Mary Jane Watson and
Peter Parker to to their own affairs
where they both basically kind of run
over things you know that are going on
with them and everything that's sort of
happening and what ends up taking place
here is Mary Jane Watson reveals to
Peter Parker that she's actually
pregnant now one thing to keep in mind
is that by the time this story had
happened Mary Jane Watson had already
come become aware of the idea of Ben
Wylie this is a guy running around out
there that's basically the clone of
Peter Parker in a lot of ways Peter
didn't really keep a whole lot of
secrets from Mary Jane and that's one of
the reasons why so many people were
upset about the fact that their marriage
basically came to an end during one more
day because it was sort of a Hallmark
marriage in a lot of different ways sort
of your traditional landscape when it
came to characters that were getting
together the other half of this is that
as Peter Parker begins to regain his
memories from this whole experience and
as the illness begins to come back down
on him again
he basically realizes that Doctor
Octopus was the one who saved his life
and so what is it happening here there's
Peter Parker transitions and actually
goes over to Doctor Octopus to try to
bring him back now this is kind of a
rough situation just because of the fact
that remember if you're Peter and one of
your most notable enemies saves your
life you can't help but think that
there's like a nefarious goal here right
like they're up to something if there's
some ulterior motive here now for Doctor
Octopus that's true that's exactly the
case he's not intending to kill Peter
Parker in the mind of Doctor Octopus
it's more of a pride thing it's more of
like Peter Parker's his main nemesis and
if anybody was going to kill Peter
Parker it's going to be Doctor Octopus
that's really the only motivation for
why it is that he's doing this in curing
spider-man Doctor Octopus knows his
identity he knows he's Peter Parker now
this put Marvel in a bit of a pickle and
a little bit of a predicament because
this is almost like the Civil War reveal
before Civil War those are the guys that
never read the Civil War comics one of
the biggest moments to take place in
that story was when Peter Parker
revealed his identity to the world right
like iron man came along said hey look
man you got to trust this Registration
Act I promise
we'll keep your family and friends safe
you have to demonstrate to the world
that you believe in it Peter Parker
unmasked himself I said like I'm a
superhero who has definitively kept his
identity hidden away from the rest of
the world here's how much I believe in
the superhuman Registration Act and then
almost immediately after that happens
there's an attempt on the life of Aunt
May so again it wasn't really you know
the the best instance but the fact
remains that it was you know another one
of these scenarios where puts Marvel in
a pickle after spider-man revealed his
identity in civil war they had to put
the cat back in the bag by having Doctor
Strange issue this giant you know spell
more or less across the world that
nobody would know the identity of Peter
Parker unless he intentionally revealed
it to them hints the whole reason with
Spider Island and those events it
unfolded and so on and so forth but with
regards to this is very similar if
Doctor Octopus knows the secret identity
of Peter Parker this is on a much
smaller scale from civil war then how
does Marvel in turn answer that how do
they counter with that well of course it
will end up finding out as a story
unfolds but again so I'm going to keep
in mind Kane in the background watching
events unfold and this is how we saw him
for a bulk of this story for a majority
of the phone saga story a lot of it
really just revolved around Ben Riley
and in spider-man you know Peter Parker
will just kind of emphasize them
emphasized their own individual stories
how they were dealing with everything
because remember in our last video when
we talked about Ben Riley we basically
established that with him coming to
terms with Peter Parker he had gone
forward as his own superhero in the form
of Scarlet Spider there was a way for
Marvel to begin the process of sort of
removing Peter Parker from the equation
and putting Ben Riley in its place now
of course with Peter Parker going back
to Doctor Octopus and essentially saying
look you know you got to help me cure
this you got to help me get rid of this
poison or this virus Doctor Octopus
helps him Doctor Octopus is able to help
them you know eliminate this illness and
in the process Peter kind of has these
visions where he sees Uncle Ben and he
encounters his biological parents and
different things like that the
experiences Norman Osborn you know his
various villain bases and different
things like that again this is part of
that whole aspect of you know the last
thing you see before you die your life
kind of flashing before your eyes but
it's also a reminder to Peter Parker of
all the things that he hasn't done of
all of his shortcomings the failures
that he's made over the course of his
life because in a lot of ways this was
designed to say goodbye to Peter now
this would not be the means by which
Marvel would try to ride him out not at
all instead it would be something a
little more organic it a little more
visceral but again this is one of those
things you
the five people you see before you die
you know when your life flashes before
your eyes and all the mistakes that
you've made for Peter Parker is looking
back unlike the death of Gwen Stacy at
the hand of Norman Osborn and this is
significant because of the fact that
while he is visiting Uncle Ben while he
has seen these various people he's
whisked away by Norman Osborn and so
what does does is it hits home at the
idea that the tried and true villain of
Peter Parker really more so than
anything else is Norman Osborn himself
Norman Osborn has almost always been
there Norman Osborn has taken some of
the most significant members of Peter
Parker's life Gwen Stacey being a
perfect example is this representation
that Peter Parker has constantly failed
and the Green Goblin manifests in that
form that Peter Parker will never find
happiness but he'll never be free of his
life of spider-man and it hits on a
couple different things in a lot of ways
Peter is his own worst enemy when it
comes to trying to live a normal life
his moral compass is the roadblock in
his path to try to live a normal life
one of the big deals with regards to the
renew your vows story in secret Wars was
it that gave us a scenario whereby a guy
named The Regent rose up and then fought
all the different superheroes and Peter
Parker walked away because Mary Jane and
his daughter were in jeopardy and so
because of that he ended up you know
saving the life of those he cared about
or at least saving the life of Mary Jane
and killed venom in the process but in
return all the major superheroes were
killed by Regent Peter Parker walked
away from being a superhero to save
those he cared about that's not
something that we would normally see
that's why that story was so huge and it
was like wow I mean it was so
groundbreaking because Peter Parker will
go to the bitter end in order to you
know be a superhero to play the role of
a superhero he'll worry about his family
first but he's not one to keep his head
down even if he's the last superhero
fighting even if he's the last guy he'll
take pot shots he'll put his mind to
task whatever the case may be he'll
always keep coming back in an effort to
try to win the day and so that's one of
the big things about this is because
this kind of gives us a story whereby we
see Peter Parker doing the best that he
can
having to go you know alongside Doctor
Octopus submit himself to this
particular scenario but again it's
constantly this idea that he'll never be
able to find happiness it's constantly
this idea that his own moral compass
gets in the way his need to be a
superhero his desire to do the right
thing is ultimately what keeps them from
being to know being able to walk away
from being a superhero at all so these
are some of the significant moments that
we saw in this particular story now the
other half of this is that of course we
end up having Doctor Octopus sort of
engineer this in
higher calamity whereby he has you know
stunner simply notify the cops that
doctor octopus's here I'm turning
himself in more or less the cops show up
they arrest him and they sort of call it
a day now again Doctor Octopus knows
he's going to get out of here I mean he
knows he's going to get away he's going
to be able to engineer his own escape
that's not going to be a great big huge
deal that's the expectation what we end
up finding out is the best laid plans of
mice and men you know it doesn't work
out that way ultimately Doctor Octopus
is sought out by Cain and Cain
essentially kills dr. octopus me just
absolutely tears him apart takes him out
step by step now the crazy thing about
this is dr. octopus is very human here
he's not a villain he's not a bad guy
how dare you step on my turf how dare
you try to you know invade my life not
at all doctor octopus's main concern is
where is stunner where's the woman that
I love and that's what's so cool about
this is much like superior spider-man it
grounded him it made him a god we can
relate to you in a lot of ways because
this is not Doctor Octopus the villain
this is Otto Octavius the person trying
to find a lot of his life concerned more
about her than he is about himself now
force again this leads to him being
killed by Kane which of course you know
stunners there to sort of mourn him and
that leads into the actual funeral for
Doctor Octopus himself but at this point
we transition over to the whole idea of
Peter Parker and where things go next
with regards to Peter himself the
prospect of Mary Jane Watson being
pregnant introduces a lot of scenarios
that are relatively dangerous for him
that was really the whole basis behind
you know renew your vows that's why
stories like that have their roots in
Clone Saga because with Peter Parker
looking at Mary Jane Watson and
realizing that she's pregnant no being
told that she's pregnant
it introduces the notion that now
there's somebody else there there's
somebody else as part of this bigger
picture there's a child to raise and
he's not going to put his child in
harm's way he has no intention of doing
that at the same time Ben Riley
approaches spider-man and says look I
gotta quit I gotta walk away I have to
be done with all this because Ben
Riley's kind of living in the shadow of
Peter Parker right like I mean that was
the whole basis behind spider-man The
Lost years it's this idea that Ben Riley
from the time that he survived an
amazing spider-man number 149 a really
the time that he was created leading up
to this point right here he's constantly
been in the shadow of Peter Parker he's
never been his own man he's never been
able to sit down and say I'm my own
guide had my own experiences you know I
am definitively a wholly different
person at the end of the day the
memories he has are the memories of
Peter Parker they're not his own they're
not memories he experienced when he was
five years old they're not memories
experience when he was 10 years old when
he remembers you know gwen stacy being
killed that's not an experience he had
it's an experience that was given to him
just by virtue of being cloned and so
this whole idea sets the stage for the
possibility of Ben Riley going off being
his own character getting his own
stories outside of the existing
spider-man stories now at the same time
Peter looks around the entire scenario
looks back on his own memories and
realizes the life that he has coming for
him later on down the line and
ultimately makes a decision that he's
going to throw away the idea of being
spider-man for him he's got a life to
live this is the moment at which Marvel
began the process of trying to write
Peter Parker out or at least they
intended to by basically having Peter
Parker say look I've got a much bigger
life to live here I can't simply allow
myself to be spider-man anymore because
my role as a superhero should anybody
learn my identity would put my family in
jeopardy not only that he looks at the
life that he could have had he looks at
the experiences that he gained with Aunt
May all those different situations and
says I want to be that person I want to
be that dad I want to be the dad that I
never had I want to pass the lessons on
that I gained from Uncle Ben to my child
now a lot of this was also sort of poked
and prodded by Aunt May just because of
the fact that would Aunt May facing the
prospect of death Peter Parker is forced
to realize that life is short and that's
one of the reasons why this is so cool
is because in this moment when aunt made
her favor basically begins to come back
and the idea is that Aunt May is going
to die Peter Parker kind of you know
begins to realize look I mean you know
tomorrow's promised to no man it's the
same experience that anybody has when
they lose someone close to them you're
forced to basically realize that life is
too short you don't get second chances
do everything that you can now because
there is no chance to do it over again
you know you don't get it take two you
are born into this world you pass away
and that's it I don't mean to say that
to make it sound cynical or anything and
that's always how I've kind of looked at
it you know and so because of this it's
really kind of a great moment because
when Aunt May officially passes away
this is when Peter Parker is at his most
base it's most human because remember
Aunt May was the source of everything I
mean Uncle Ben was huge losing Uncle Ben
was a huge moment but it's what set
Peter Parker on the path of becoming
spider-man losing on May he might as
well have losses for world
she's the cornerstone of everything that
he values it's losing his mom for all
intents and purposes and so in these
moments when he's forced to basically
experience this entire situation he
effectively intends to sit down and say
done I'm done being spider-man I'm gonna
go live my life I've been a superhero
long enough I fought alongside the
Avengers long enough I've given enough
I've lost enough it's time for me to go
live my life everybody else will be okay
then Riley the skull and Spyder he can
just take over he could just be the new
spider-man it's not a great big huge
deal we look the same anyway so as far
as anybody knows it knows us
individually knows as people nothing's
going to be the same to them he has all
my same memories so you guys see where
Marvel was going with with this idea of
removing Peter Parker and replacing him
with Ben Riley the issue with this is
that before any of that can happen
because of these murders that came has
been going around and committing the
police pick up on Peter Parker because
remember came and in Peter Parker at
least this was the first indication
Caine as we know now is a clone of Peter
Parker and so because of this the
fingerprints that Caine's been leaving
behind our Peter Parker's fingerprints
to all individuals who were
investigating this the identity of the
person who's committed these crimes is
Peter Parker himself and so Peter
Parker's tossed in the paddy wagon and
hauled off to jail and what this does is
set the stage for the entire you know
trial of Peter Parker himself and the
revelation of who Caine is where Cain
came from and ultimately who it is
behind all these clones that are
cropping up with regards to the
spider-man landscape what would that
being said guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come as explained make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
love